trouve qu'on est dimanche j'y peux rien
j'ai le droit on est dimanche bordel
nain jeux 3d dimanche
non mais bon un dimanche c'est quand
même moi on veut pas revoir peut parler
des jours de la semaine
c'est un sujet intéressant en tout cas
on est là on est là je suis là pour le
moment je eu droit aux
mais bon on est là on est là et écouter
j'attends j'attends que vous arrivez
dans le chat pour un peu discuté hier
voilà il faut le savoir
donc il va y avoir le tournoi mais bon
vous savez que quand c'est moi qui
stream c'est à larache total à un pain
va-t-on vraiment commenter les parties
de ce tour je suis loin d'en être sûr
donc je vais mettre le lien déjà dans le
chat une première fois mais enfin où
sont-ils quoi où sont les gens où êtes
vous l'élite de la nation
moi je vais arriver ou pas à saillé
l'élite aridjis cas et salue caisse à
lui dit salut tonton comment ça va t'on
comment ça se passe à l'ust ailleurs
salut rené ouais je parlais dans vitus
parler dans le vide
je parle je parle de choses trop
élitiste on arrive salut tout le monde
salue gn naturel gêne ou pas salut la
capote masques et voilà elle est là le
soir je vous vois moins parce que je
suis tellement mode try hard la capote
masqué salut mohammed 22 88 salut
alevins de 2018
ça on le laissera pas tout seul
t'inquiète si si toi même tu sais ça lui
dimitri 18,86 low-kick génération qui a
des gens qui regardent plus les strings
la journée il ya des gens qui regardent
plus la nuit
il ya des loups garous quoi dans le dans
le chat la can terre et qui sont avec
moi jusqu'à une 2h du mat en train de
blitz et j'ai fini comment je suis
remonte à 2007 finalement mohamed
je suis monté je suis descendu je suis
remonté je suis redescendu et j'ai
rejoué contre le même turkmène et je
fais je les relais français je suis
arrivé
2007 et on allait faire du tfc je
comprends derrière une nouvelle carte
c'est être c'était n'importe quoi hier
soir c'était vraiment n'importe quoi
mais on a kiffé on a kiffé on a kiffé
c'était cool c'était couleurs ce soir
normalement il y avait la première à
draria à 17 heures mais j'ai plus aucune
nouvelle
alors est ce qu'ils m'ont annulé ça je
sais pas ce qu'ils foutent
peu importe j'ai envie de dire et ça lui
dit jean roch grob les turkmènes le
turkménistan et en sueur c'était énorme
le tfc mais j'y comprends rien il ya
trop de nouvelles cartes je déteste le
nouveau design les mecs
pourquoi est ce qu'ils ont fait 1
pourquoi il avait un truc bien et ils
ont tout changé
ce soir à l'aréna un nouveau format mais
je ne sais pas réflexe du 59
on m'a dit ça on baptise est on allé
dimanche tu stream j'ai dit bah ouais je
suis là je vais je vais poser mes
couilles mais mes yeux coup sûr la reina
et tu peux à faire le tour et fait feu
je préfère faire l'aréna l'aréna derijck
quoi moi je veux jouer je joue et je
jouais avec les durs balech de l'aréna
ffe les mecs c'est très bien qu'ils
fassent l'aréna bravo mais mais j'ai
envie jouer à l'aréna de chaises comme
bordel j'ai le droit
c'est le retour des arénas on est très
chaud ça va trash talk tu vois j'ai
envie de la cola tout le monde là je
suis chaud ma femme m'a dit faut que tu
mettes le tee-shirt noir ce soir
bitstream
c'est quoi une wave d'euralair hainard
alors ça va être ce bot lane ou
extraordinaire parce que tout le monde
peut gagner un prix donc là allez-y
festival quoi c is ou night club de
partout ça va trash talk pendant deux
heures je vais être hyper énervé dès la
première je vais wrench renren je suis
pas content est-ce que j'ai une nouvelle
de vue-là il est revenu en france ben
non il est chez lui à moscou vlad et
donc notre aréna aujourd'hui pour moi
est que cet or qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi ne sommes nous que cette je
mets le lien dans le chat non anglade il
y parvient d'une ans est chez lui à
moscou tranquille pekouz
p pouces beppu zh
alors cela est fait mans à voir sa
chasse comme fr voilà on est bien on est
bien en direct et le lien je te mets à
sya qu il est là ou là
du coup du coup c'est stream inception
joa joie le voit le jeu voit le live là
bas alors attendez attendez attendez
attendez on est bon on est bon les gars
et ça lui réussit chat link tard un
magnet je suis toujours là toujours
présent toujours super canton barret un
sais combien d'années que je suis la
chaîne manu ça fait min 4 ans dans aia
vix qui jouera les jamais vu lui et bien
non le voit hélas le droit et merci à
fred power pour le sahb merci tonton
deuxième mois d'abonnement merci merci
fred power ouais donc l'aréna les
tontons 13 15 1 ouais je suis revenu à
2000 2007
greg l'échec des saluts piotte moskva
4,5 en ouest fait longtemps que tu es la
manu manu tête partout en droit un peu
plus sur le disent quand comme tu tapes
moi en ce moment ça va sinon la famille
ça se passe oh [ __ ] et un bourdon qui
il ya un bourdon qui rôde et il s'est
paraît il à rodez parce qu'en fait il ya
les petites abeilles qui viennent je
vais tolère complètement les bourdons
déjà tu vois je l'entends dû venir
tu vois j'ai des oreilles qui se lève
j'ai les oreilles qui pointe
tu vois et alors le bourdon ne fait
semiper serre que vous allez me voir
courir sortir et puis revenir avec une
serviette
par contre
par contre s'il y a celui qu'on appelle
l famose au frelon asiatique
là ça se peut qu'on broyer plus sur le
stream pendant 15 minutes
c'est à dire que tant qu'il y aura un
frelon asiatique dans cette pièce il y
en a un qui se ramène à un moment donné
je ne rentre pas dans la pièce tant que
le frelon asiatique est là donc ça voilà
faut bien le savoir tant qu'il ne sera
pas parti je ne reviendrai pas d'accord
donc ça faut le savoir le frelon
asiatique me fait peur j'ai peur des
frelons asiatiques voilà ça c'est
quelque chose que je vous dis les
frelons asiatiques mes frais le frelon
asiatique et âgée j'ai les oreilles la
plage et là que j'ai là qu en bas que
voilà j'ai les oreilles vers le haut je
pars j'ai hyper peur le frelon asiatique
mais frais ouais non mes frais ouais
t'as raison trade icq les guêpes et les
autres les quêtes les gars tu vois tu
l'as en mode tu vois je fais du tai chi
ça va je gère une guêpe encore
encore une fois j'ai failli perdre la
vue à cause d'une grippe je raconterai
peut-être sur un stream j'ai failli
perdre la vue à cause d'une grippe les
mac
le jeu pourrait prouver le no fake en
faisant venir ma mère sur le sur le truc
le no fake pour être pourrai prouver
qu'ils essayent par là la vue est
mais les gars je gère le bourdon déjà
pour moi voilà il fait trop il fait trop
peur mais les bonbons sont gentils ouais
mais bon enfin quand même il est un peu
gros quoi après le frelon asiatique
enfin je suis
j'en peux plus quoi vous avez d'échelle
vous avez déjà été confronté en 1 v1 un
frelon asiatique le chat ou pas les
araignées ça va
les araignées honnêtement j'en ai
sûrement sur mon truc que tu vois je ne
relève même pas l'étoile est pour moi
une araignée est un allié face aux
moustiques
c'est à dire que pour moi tu vois c'est
un peu tu vois c'est un peu et georgia
fonds pai heures c'est à dire que moi
j'aimais araignée jeu les comptes et tu
vas c'est un moment donné quand on va se
friter avec les moustiques tigres ou
house genre de conneries pour moi
l'araignée édenté dans ma team si tu
veux donc on fait tu vois je respecte
l'araignée non mais les frelons
asiatiques ils sont effrayants ils sont
vraiment effrayant déjà premièrement ils
sont gros deuxièmement il te pique it
font mal troisièmement ils sont
agressifs et quatrièmement eux
alors j'ai vu une news je sais pas si
c'est une fille avec news alors je sais
pas à voir à quel point c'est vrai ou
c'est faux mais apparemment en chine
donc la légende c'est pas un puisque on
sait ce que les chiffres sont vrais on
ne sait plus mais apparemment en chine
il ya des gars dans des dans des petits
villages donc des gars qui sont des
terres déchets dans les petits villages
donc des dégâts des terres qui se serait
fait attaqué par des frelons encore plus
gros que d'habitude c'est à dire que
c'est c'est les frelons asiatiques des
asiatiques
si tu veux nous on avait le frelon de
base il ya le frelon asiatique qui
arrive et on s'est dit merde le gars et
des terres et eux ils ont le frelon
asiatique de djazia tic tu as et le
frelon asiatique du frelon asiatique
c'est qu'il est doublement asiatique est
apparemment très agressif et plus gros
que le frelon qu'on a chez nous de chez
eux et est apparemment alors là encore
c'est très possible c'est une fête news
c'est même probable mais ces frelons
aurait tué 12 personnes serre qu'ils
seraient arrivés en masse ils auraient
dit voilà les gars il y en a marre vous
vous foutez la merde avec le co vide le
machin le truc
nous on est voilà une association de
frelons c'est sait même pas
l'association en russie on est un
syndicat des frelons voilà le syndicat
des frelons vénère et on en a marre on
en a marre de ce qui se passe et il voit
là ils sont ils sont venus ils ont ils
ont expliqué comment ça allait se passer
à partir de maintenant
et apparemment les gars auraient peur si
tu veux je me dis déjà que moi j'ai peur
du frelon de base asiatique jeu mais
d'ici là ces frelons là qui viennent je
vais tout faire mais je ne sors plus de
chez moi
c'est à dire que là vous demeurez même
plus dehors avec le masque c'est à dire
que là moi je suis en combinaison pour
pour faire de la pi logique hong kong
qui s'appelle ça quand tu fais les
abeilles la sepa de l'api logis c'est
quoi le mollet mais avec les mecs le
chat l'apiculture apiculture voilà pile
au gie apiculture apiculture merci
dimitri je suis en sueur chercheurs et
si tu veux en combinaison d'apiculture
sans arrêt c'est à dire que là moi c'est
des trucs comme ça dehors je ne suis tu
ne me vois plus dehors en fait ça va
être très simple tout ça pour dire que
ouais tout ça pour dire que voilà si
vous n'avez jamais été leur face à
enlever un contre un frelon asiatique
vous ne savez vous ne savez pas quel
point ces gars sont des terres en
revanche j'ai toujours j'ai de plus en
plus d'abeilles sur mon balcon alors ça
c'est un peu la bonne nouvelle du jour
le nombre des abeilles qui viennent
butiner messi trop niais donc j'ai un
petit balcon grandit de jour en jour et
là on vit en osmose si tu veux c'est à
dire que les abeilles viennent la
terrasse n'est pas très grand mais elle
y est sur son petit citronniers moi je
suis assis tranquille je vois mes
petites et mes petits matches à mes
petits cafés et julien on a réussi à
trouver un terrain d'entente il n'y a
aucune agressivité c'est tu vois c'est
c'est un genre d'amitié inter-espèces
quoi donc avec les abeilles pour le
monde ça se passe bien
ça se passe pas mal avec les petits
moineaux devant et on a un qui commence
un peu à venir aujourd'hui c'est assis
en face de moi j'ai orient lemoine riez
partie mais tu vois je sens je sens
qu'il ya une certaine tu as une certaine
connexion qui est en train de se passer
avec avec les abeilles déjà avec les
petits moineaux donc c est en train de
bien se passer
les abeilles sont nos amis mais
complètement complètement complètement
j'essaye de les aider en fait j'essaye
de les aider parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'elle galère avec les fleurs elle
galère elle galère elles reviennent tous
les jours sur les mêmes fleurs je sais
pas ce qu'elles font alors les abeilles
c'est fantastique
battus en ayant plus de contact social
avec avec des personnes j'ai des
contacts sociaux avec des abeilles fatwa
jeu je communie avec dame nature
imaginons un problème avec le convient
de nommer le frelon haussant le coût
vide de toute façon en vain il en a même
pas besoin le frelon donc je remette le
lien de la reina mais je me disais un
truc de ouf quoi mca
t'imagines si les moustiques peuvent
passer le coc vide
déjà que je les déteste les moustiques
je ne supporte pas ces gens il ne
m'intéresse pas mais mais imagine si en
plus ils te passe des maladies ce serait
fou quoi
chinois vont bouffer les moustiques
travées c'est fou le kobe n'est pas
transparent rien et tu ne sais pas puis
c'est par renault 84,31 un moustique tu
vois une nouvelle sorte de moustiques
peut-être il te prends le virus sur ces
sur ses pattes et le transmet on ne sait
pas il te touche un peu les gouttelettes
vers le nez j'en sais rien moi ils ont
dit sur france 2 ouais mais si l'on dit
sur france2 grand maître gims je me
méfie ils m'ont quand même dit que
c'était une grippette il ya deux mois
ils m'ont dit que ils m'ont dit beaucoup
de choses ils m'ont dit que les masques
ne servait à rien les moustiques de la
conférence est par nature non mais
normalement non parlons sérieusement
c'est pas censé y sont pas censés le
transmettre je veux ici quand même je
suis je suis en total méfiance bonne
partie les raye dit timothey ben moi une
bonne partie riou si je me suis levé
j'ai le droit bordel d'être méfiant non
en vrai en vrai moi je dis un peu les
rapports de l'om est parfois de temps en
temps pas tous les jours mais une fois
par semaine je regarde un peu et c'est
intéressant
honnêtement c'est intéressant je vous
recommande de vous souvenir comment le
truc en fait si vous lisez un peu
l'anglais je crois que c'est même
traduit manger en anglais après mais à
bien y regarder on va regarder manu
dignard aller selon tan qui suit la
chaîne manu à laymont manu poulet manu
poulet j'ai eu poulets ils jouent contre
hugo 30 94 à laymont man u man u
manu d'amener 3 pts qui on prend et
d'amd trois vagues
il le sait bourdeilles le sait manier
qui suit les noms manille manu est
pourquoi il fait ça dont manu pourquoi
tu me fais ça à moi manul manu dame b 3
minutes attaque le pion bessette et le
pion des 5 es tu gagnes la partie qui
fait d'un v6 pour défendre et échanger
les dames tu prends des saints qui prend
b3 tu prend ainsi sur échec l'aurait
fait à prend b3 montmagny mon petit van
hulle non non non oh non il fait
n'importe quoi manu y fait n'importe
quoi les amis au nom et c'est la vérité
les amis et c'est la vérité assez fou
c'est fou ou manu rolala in-stat qui
envoie un pénible sur le chat manu
comment tu peux me faire ça manu depuis
tant d'années qu'on se connaît et le
charpentier créé écrit soultana le
charpentier ça va bien se passer
ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
on va les regarder tu es parti ça va
bien se passer bien se passer ne
t'inquiète pas ne t'inquiète pas tu
risques élevés aiea et charpentier les
valeurs là on va le trouver
on fait quand pour jouer ap le lien du
tournoi
car après apprend v3 fou c'est de
regagner le pion pour les noirs alors
attention attention les yeux c'est de
regagner le pion et non qui a été de peu
le protéger mais je ne sais pas si le
maire poussez pas eu trois de laisser le
pion est développé et en vrai t'as juste
une bonne structure de pions baignoire
la structure des fonds c'est pas le pion
des cats qui a qui y performent peu
trois des quatre qui perfore il va se
développer de mettre une tour en c1 et
développement plus rapide et à le centre
et les blancs sont très très bien alors
mon manu tu es ce qui me fait me change
d'état mais ils sévissent et sur ses 4
ou pas fou 17,6 doit être le coup
à brega les deux fous les cages mais
sûrement il faut jouer ce que j'ai
montré après il faut des 2/3 food et roy
s'attend à payants et non content c'est
gratuit les amis il est gratuit le
tournoi donc je vous remette le lien de
partout à tan tan tan tan tan c'est quoi
c'est quoi ces motifs c'est manu qui
m'écrit faut que j'enlève j'enlève les
notifs mais tu as regardé si c'est mon
manu mais non c'est pas mon manu c'est
pas mon manu qui m'a écrit alors il a
pris ici qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
faire un petit roi des oeufs et a juste
perdu un point en fait mon manu bon ben
il va falloir revoir sa manière il va
falloir que tu revois ça est peut-être
tombé 5 well tomber cinq tours c'est un
jeu c'est un peu la gueule quoi six
tours b5 b6 des six tours c'est 8
on va voir on va voir si simon manu s'en
sort en tout cas bravo à hugo est ce que
hugo et dans le tchat
hugo le petit hugo est demandé dans le
chat le petit hugo 30,94 séparant la
pelle
hugo
alors d'ailleurs le côté de mary m qui
bat le champion du monde d'échecs
bizarre je pense je sais pas que c'est
mary mg pas je fais pas tu passes tes
des échos est-ce que hugo et dans le
tchad j'en sais rien moi attend la
capote masque électro kaiser il parle de
quoi en fait il qu je suis son père non
vraiment pour de vrai lecourbe hauteur x
hunter ouais faut que je regarde j'ai vu
qu'ils étaient recommandés sur l'effet
turaci s'est vite là sont trop réfléchir
parce que sur puis on prend fopits
retour ces intermédiaires non
puis on prend qui on prend et après la
tour en c1 ou en c2 on échange annoncé
une vague leur son site de je suis tombé
axsguard je suis dit c'est moi son père
en fait il est pas sur le chat hugo quoi
une usure go ne tache pas x hunter x
hunter smith
il finira jamais tu conseilles de pas
regarder ce bip bip
on va voir la finale normalement il va
la gagner tranquille on va voir mais
c'est tellement dommage pour manu
dignard c'est tellement dommage il avait
la game 1 entre ses doigts
il avait sa et de la game entre ses
doigts et yomou me dégage jo bon et
manon et fort qu'il envoyait y ont peint
maintenant faut envoyer il faut envoyer
les lions temps vous pouvez changer les
tours je vous recommande vraiment
berzerk les mecs que ce soit en animé ou
en face à face à shawn lanoue manga que
c'est un manga plus tôt mais franchement
je recommande un werder je recommande de
ouf je vous recommande de ouf c'est pas
mal il a fait le truc qu'il a fait là
fait une petite erreur là notre ami hugo
normalement tu pousses le pion qui a pas
d'opposition tu fais bessin 4 5 b 4 à 4
baies 3 le truc son tu fais ac 5 à 4 la
manu il a réussi à faire un bloc de bon
alors après il va réussir à faire
baisser un coup quoi mais il aurait pu
faire un peu illusion bernard sur
netflix ouais t'as deux versions regarde
la version la plus ancienne elle est
bien mieux que la nouvelle j'ai regardé
les deux même si je connaissais
l'histoire est un beau coup bien
ouais l'âge d'or mais après tu as
maintenant c'est bien moi je suis
d'accord avec toi
tenza wisa with the wolf nom mélanie mai
bien mai à electro kaiser mais l'ancien
anime le nouveau est pourri mais le
vieil animé bien mais le nouveau nuls
c'est quoi le cheeseburger que c'est un
gars qui il arrive que des merdes en
gros il manie peut-être peu nan mais
c'est dommage les pions quand vous avez
une structure comme ça c'est propre
parce que si une tour vient les manger
c'est un deux trois quatre cinq coups
l'a aimé son pion f4 maintenant s'il se
fait taper lui en fait c'est facile de
remanger ça j'aime bien il va chercher
peut-être le contre je mets le roi
pénètre et peut-être à 4 au 6 mai elle
était dure à défendre mais en fait sont
rois il est parti de l'autre côté
maintenant le maintenant à quatre a321
sa fille l'un joue pas le tournant sur
l'appui direct et je sais pas comment ça
marche avec l'appli je trouve jamais non
plus en fait la nouveau et départ lancé
la suite de l'ancien faire tomber 8
échec à tours à huit la tour attaque à 4
non c'était pas la suite non ils ont
refait la même histoire en fait le sur
le nouveau animée et saül frais dans la
chambre kla ces morts là pour maniche
est ce que je regarde la quadrette
rappelle j'ai pas eu le temps encore
j'étais j'étais trop occupé à stream est
remonté au-dessus de 2007 alors à bien
regarder un peu ce tchèque
c'est quoi il fait une carreau
ça va bien ça shake cette petite caro la
whey manu c'est dommage qu'il ait perdu
d'accueil milla il a raté le tam b3 dont
l'ouverture après on n'y peut rien manu
chao ouais ouais et complètement ou la
c4 dans la france dans une structure
française fab il aimerait parent aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe heureusement que fab
suis pas famille nous a dit structure
française pousse ses pions c'est
interdit 1 ça fait mal salut la cuisse
44 vous pouvez apprendre et progresser
grâce aux entraînements il son idée très
heureux vous battre vous prend pions
prend tout re en cavale et la faim et le
pion illescas donnant mais dans les
structures françaises poussent espions
c'est rarement bon encore là il avait le
fou devant mais mais bon là il va il va
le perdre 1 carrément dit pourra pas le
protéger
après qu'il y avait trois on joue quoi
bas j'aurais quand même pris un chaos
bon c'est un peu de la merde aussi ma
fallait anticiper
anticipé tant pis dommage mais c'est 4
dans ces structures là déjà mais super
c'est dommage pour lui regardez sens
c'est une bonne série j'aime bien sinon
en manga shonan il ya naruto est mais
naruto
alors ces quatre baies 5 à 50 ans mais
si tu veux en fait dans cette stricte
avec le fou devant ce pas si grave mais
là c'est à chaque 1200 il faut pas
qu'ils fassent
il comprend pas pourquoi il fait voilà
c'est un cas spécial où c'est peut-être
pas si grave
mais bon peu importe
bref c'est juste fini non il reste 30 c
quatre et ses morts ses morts
bon alors quand il conclu cook est
pareil c'est un prêt d'en faire un peu d
x 3 comme la partie de maxime contre
n'est pas la dernière partie officielle
que maxime a joué et qui jouera pendant
un bon moment pour aller dominé les
cases noires
mike rang
et qu'elle arrive à faire d'un match 4
s'ils peuvent on y trouve du compte
quand même avec les noirs c'est vrai que
c'est réussi à faire des ravages
4 bon il y aura tirage 3 puis on prend
il faudra quand même trop de temps pour
mater un ca des fois à 3 qui arrive mais
tant que le va-tout j'ai envie de dire
bazire
tant pis 1 on n'a qu'une vie moyenne des
six qui fait mal qui avait lieu cette
dame prend b8 c'est vrai que fait la
gueule mais bon on n'a qu'une vie un
ballet si je fais quand même sacrément
la gare
cette fois trois aussi quelquefois trois
qui ces cinq n'ont rempli en train
d'apprendre qu'à valence a su réussir à
faire ça tu es très heureux adams et si
madame liesman way
et ouais tu fais la gueule mais bien
tenté sachet qui l'attend et la quittes
attaque
ça fait mal on va on va passer à 1 tient
un petit mon petit cryptage ou pas la
partie stable ou un regard un peu les
les gars que je connais bien
un câble j'ai le droit il est passé amin
amin qui joue aujourd'hui vient en garde
amin wardak c'est mon ami nival arnaquer
c'est sa marque de fabrique
9 2 y démarrant à mine et paris 15 ans
avec un 100 m va bientôt vrai ce sera
organisée par cech 24 du coup la cuisse
donc on pourra pas j'imagine le
commenter mais à moins que on et j'ai
pas à moins qu'ils fassent je vois le
truc sur tous les serveurs ou quoi mais
je pense qu'il le j'imagine que gardien
sur leur site j'en sais rien mais ouais
ça aura lieu mi avril
j'ai une dame contre trop de pièces à
l'est de kiev
ouais mais c'est chiant ça une dame
compte trop de pièces lvl c'est maxime
vachier lagrave hugo rixe c'est le
numéro un français vitrine chaffraix
halabi strict avants français
on n'a pas pouvoir exactement faire ce
qu'on a voulu vous ce qu'on voulait
faire de base du coup les gars mais il
ya plusieurs idées mais en fait on va
commencer par un truc caritatif
normalement le week-end prochain
j'attends j'attends encore des mails de
confirmation c'est beaucoup plus
difficile d'organiser que prévu mais
normalement à peut-être faire un petit
truc pelouse en fait
alors
ouais il ya enfin de 4q d'un match 4 mon
aline pour ses huits 3,7 à alger cinq
rois justice n'y a peut-être pas de
maths pour ces 6 6 peut-être il s'en
sort complètement là j'imagine qu'à pas
de matha temps je mette un coup d'ordi
adam 5 d'abord f6 tour ses huit 3g cèdre
et dans ce temps là d'un procès 3,6 soit
il ya un match je regardais pas assez à
aller c'est la même en fait c'est le dam
dam 5 à mesdames 5,3 h61 mesdames f4s ça
sentait pas très bon
dames 5 faire c'est pas de chance
moi j'ai sept dont g5 croyait fuite
y'a pas de mater avec quoi il n'y avait
pas g5 juste échec la bassée aïe aïe aïe
la rate et j'ai cinq échecs au la mine
amis d'amis d'incroyable mais bon ce pas
fini dams et 6 mai à ce matin en 1 re
aiment bien faire tour c5 sûrement pour
couvrir dame alors elle est maintenant
il rata must hills alors maintenant pour
couvrir là il va faire dame cinq tours
sévit 3g cette dame cinq dames f6
d'hommes v8 dame prend un f3 tour g8 à
l'enm et on july 3 prend le ses protégés
aulas il a craqué il a craqué et tour
ces deux là auraient tort c'est de plus
facile vous veillez à gagner ça est un
truc facile juste envers assez peu de
temps vous mettez à tour ans et de ses
protégés vous pouvez pré mou jusqu'au
bout du monde le roi est bloqué en faire
juste gafsi commença à faire ça faudra
enlever le pré mais vous serez obligé de
revenir mais ce n'est pas le pion d un
peu près mou jusqu'au bout du monde et
c'est un par un elle était sympa ta
petite partie alors mon petit cristal où
il fait quoi il fut souvent des parties
marrante ils envoient il fait du sale
salut marcy psycho
ouais j'ai 5 c'est dommage qu'il ait
raté c'était sympa non c'est comme ça ça
arrive c'est la vie alors il fait petits
fous ces quatre salut grand big boss
ah ouais ça fait longtemps fait très
longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu le grand big
boss pas très longtemps
cadets b 4 qui rose puisque sur pions
préemption prend mais un problème là bas
et là ça va péter quelque part et ça va
faire très mal
salut blink hausse et salue noir pâle
salut tonton je suis pas resté chez
addenda taille de lutins je suis remonte
à 2007 surtout bobo 2008 hier c'était
c'était pas possible
hier 2008 était était un objectif
impossible à toutes les parties tour des
malins ya des jours comme ça ouais t'as
vu la remonte à la méta pas revu la
descende à après un bep popo parce
qu'après s'être montagne est une des 100
da
après la remonte à die et la descente
dallas et tour en échec tour à un coût
très cheikh bou bleus contre échec bien
joué bien jouer crypte al talh qui met
les poings salua juncker zagg tate à la
manne proches parlent en anglais en fait
c'est quoi le délire à free galaxie
fusée galaxy qui est premier et joue
contre le grand big boss bordel c'est
génial le grand big boss s'il est là
quoi d'alger le gros fichiers du chef
pierrot je vais te grand officier
il aurait pu car rester dans le délire
de faire rock en disant tu prends je
prends tu vas rester dans le délire
d'aidé ouf
contre échec était sympa rap système
réincarnant et vous pensez qu'on va
penser que y aura moyen de faire une
soirée en novembre l'année prochaine on
va toujours être confinés et je crois
pas que le son soit h et 15 min tit
je pense que le som marche pour tout le
monde tonton tel contrat chez que la
fois que l'on a ça il y aura toujours le
virus aurait mais du coup c'est pénible
cela qu'on pourra pas se refaire la
soirée en novembre bon cela fait quand
même et on tombe tous malades marche pas
c'est une question on prend le risque
peut prendre le risque qu'un mais alors
est ce qu'il va être le cavalier en d5
je pensais qu'ils allaient faire s'il
veut cinq ans mais pour pour jouer le
clouage par un truc bien je crois
l'attitude des parents bété de mémoire
juste je crois que sur ces 3 vous pouvez
faire des cinq direct de mémoire et
comme ça vous embête et vous ne vous
embêtez pas du tout puis on prend et je
crois que c'était prend 1,4 ce fait
comme ça et s'ils prennent de la dame
je sais plus peut-être cavaliers
affichent 6 juin tu menaces calisesi
ccif epyon prends tu prends à au pire un
ils prennent tu prends et c'est juste
égal fera que je fasse une vidéo
l'assuré club parce que là du coup il se
prend d attaquer il va finir par la
perdre ses prix en foot pro f 7 et
machin
sont à réserver à ceux qui ont développé
les anticorps et non en plus la
malchance avec ça c'est que normalement
si les calculs sont bons enfin si le si
les gens que tu as abonnés aussi vite à
la chaîne on pourra voir les 50000 à pau
en novembre prochain
ben sahar était vraiment pas mal de
faire soirée spéciale 50000 puisque
cinquante mille c'est quand même
franchement c ou cinquante mille 50
milles c'est beaucoup il ya là y entrent
ou joly il menace mate ses cavales f4
regardez-moi ça les mecs
j'attaque je défends j'attaque hills où
il n'y a pas vus
calculs ne sont pas bons c'est pour ça
que j'ai si les calculs sont bons car
les h4 à 1.136 way possiblement donc à
relief 4 juste très thématique alors à
temps froid je joue merde
j'allais jouer pour intel qui ont su à
moudre fo l'oeil allez on l'a pas vu
encore aujourd'hui ayew contre vives lui
dit pas durer je me suis fait défoncer
vrai complètement franchement
franchement j'aimerais bien de terrain
non mais en vrai oui à sac 250 en
position en position tonton caviale
story hier soir nous décrit [ __ ] je
vais me suicider si je fais que de la
merde en position latérale de serre
prêté à l'as position latérale de
celui-ci toros sueur
car on en tue pourra pas faire ta soirée
sera tour à des causes candidature
commentera ouais mais si tu fais comme
aujourd'hui on fait une soirée spéciale
50000 a beau ça va ils me disent oui à
kiev
vas-y bas mais ces belles soirées
moi je la joue pas là comme arena ce
temps on va fumer le pérou et ce soir
les mecs sac alors le match 20h22 21h25
sarion les prend en les retournant les
péruviens comme à la coupe du monde de
foot on leur avait mis combien les ans
les avait pas battu d'un gros scores non
il avait fait un bon match les péruviens
position assez symétrique là je veux
dire
deux heures c'était par apple en ans
était le père ou à bobby fischer 2 quand
même très très attention quoi en 82
juste et paraguay mais à en 2018 le
mondial à moscou
c'était le pérou match de poule je pense
et l2 c'était le deuxième ou troisième
match pour les vaches avaient dû battre
1-0 l'australie dans ce tellement
mauvais match mais vise lui il est plus
trempette pleutre pleutres c'est sûr que
c'était le pérou le deuxième match
tu mérites de père assis fait des saints
qui s'est fort quoi oui je te refais la
symétrie d'aller f4 wife de mon talent
et et on attaque la vive lui je joue
contre un maître fide je dois absolument
tirer manul aller vivre lui proche
biscaye tomber ça quand je suis en
partie chez check point comme moi je
peux ça dépend des adversaires en un qui
refuse en a qui veulent je pense qu'ils
font
c'était beau cliché points comme
cache-cache 56,6 ici il va la perdre
mais c'est bien fait pour vivre lui tu
as été pleutre tu mérites de perdre je
suis belge peut faire le match se soit
ou pas mais bien sûr contre iman et bien
sûr la france est un grand pays nous
accueillons nous accueillons nos amis
belges
nous accueillons nos amis belges dans la
team france contre iman bien entendu
bien entendu il nous serons même heureux
de ne pas avoir à nos côtés
grâce aux incas non mais on peut si on
perd on perd contre un des derniers pays
au monde à avoir trouvé la roue quand
même hein ça c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est écrit dans mon bouquin sur
l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est fou on n'a pas le droit de perdre
ce match non en fait ce que les incas en
fait pourquoi il n'avait pas trouvé la
roue bon en fait il ya c'est un pays où
il ya beaucoup de montagne ils sont trés
montagnard et
du coup en fait il n'avait pas vraiment
besoin de roues donc jamais trouvé par l
onde et la marée
mais pas des serge la main basse écrit
dans mon livre est c'est écrit dans mon
livre comprend reds à fort myer
comprendrait djaffar je fais marrer fait
pas rêver vos écrans ces frais divers
j'ai fait un super pouces je ferai avec
des fois où vous êtes confort sera
atteinte en rade par mois vous êtes trop
drôle
allez si toto qui je peux jouer contre
toi et c'est les lundis et vendredis
soirs les parties à l'ets site auto sur
la chaîne bitstream tu peux trouver le
lien juste en dessous dans cct une
enfilade qui a été ratée way ou pas well
as ya les tours c'est sa toile
effectivement je sais trop occupé à
rigoler à la blague
honnêtement c'est pas une grande finale
je vous le dis franchement c'est pas des
grands échecs et se moquerait fu lei
c'est quoi son pseudo dans le chat parce
que c'est pas l'autre maugrée fallen qui
est par là d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est
marrant c'est par là il est là tous les
jours ah non il est là maugrée fallen 44
naturel oui
on n'est pas méga nombreux sur la
renaissance est allé on essaie de faire
un peu gonflé les chiffres on peut
arriver en laissant 50 ce serait bien
mais c'est fou qu'il ait perdu sa vie vu
et ça est ce que c'est vraiment perdant
d'ailleurs tu pousses le pion ça doit
être perdant je serai plus là je suis
perdu jean pas pourquoi ça ne serait pas
mais je sais pas
marc va pouvoir cumuler les menaces
faites le pion va avancer
fary vérifier des finales il faut être
bizarre parfois et ça avance sur tft non
c'est la galère est alors j'ai voulu
regarder une vidéo sur tft justement
mais j'avais sommeil
du coup j'ai pas pu il faut que je vois
des compos et la reine elle est là et
alors attendre faut être dans le club
france démarrage mais tu tapes et le
poignet contre le truc incroyable
l'oeuvre sait plus comment c'est plus
léger plus loin du clavier à venir les
gens qui ont bien du club de chaises
comme france je galère là avec l'ordi
pour eux pour trouver retient règles y
jeter leader du tournoi les 2037 merrill
lynch sa ferrari joue contre manu
guignard manu dignard il est là il va
tout casser mon manu mais il va tout
péter manu passe devant sa fin a eu 4 5
avec b3 à b2 qu'est ce qu'il fout manu
plus tôt mais plutôt ton pions mais
plutôt ton pion aux 3 et essaie de lui
faire faux v5 pour essayer de s'en
prendre à eux cinq on man u ça va pas
très bien ensemble tout ça qu'est-ce qui
fait manu ça s'est pas développée à la
dame qui part aussi vu que au petit
bonheur la chance que tu me fais manu
qu'est-ce qui fait manu il va chercher
le pion baisse est il complètement fou
manu aujourd'hui il a pas fait d'un b3
d'un prend bessette à la première partie
ça l'a frustré
qu'est ce qui me fait manu là qu'est ce
qui fait mon manu à moi là au nom manu
depuis quand je joue aux échecs
écoute je vais pas je vais je vais te
faire peur ça fait 26 ans que je joue
aux échecs
j'espère que je n'ai pas fait flipper
aller si toto yaris 53 avenue de laon
tournoi toi petit 20-20 touati touati il
vient pour le tournoi
salut latchès à triple carmélites la
nature et au violon le dow est il ya les
oiseaux qui sont devant chez moi et tout
tu pourrais donner moins de 26 ans
gisait bah ouais mais question je suis
vieux et je suis je suis un papy gg 1
je suis un papillon m'appelle pas piqué
mines
ça ne pas dépenser un sou avoir plein de
thunes sur le compte depuis le
confinement ouais franchement telle
somme je prends des crèmes pour pareille
john non non non je bois le sens de mes
adversaires après les horreurs battue
surface comme en fait et c'est ça qui me
qui me permet de cesser une cure de
jouvence en fait vous faites comment
pour dépenser des thunes loyer pierre
pierrot nourriture impôts qu'on n'y
arrive pas qu y est on y arrive
ouais je suis un joueur de couloir
non non pierrot ouais en fait wayne a
cassé un chasseur de vampires ouais mais
tu vises elle aussi pierrot well
abonnement comme fait rajeunir aussi
c'est pas faux hein lehmann huclack la
dame ma nuque la clad à mains nues
claque adam a les mains nues claque la
dame fois six ans ferme là d'un bon pas
vraiment il ya d'abord eu quatre dames
eu trois dames c'est 3 mai mais nous on
voulut manu mais l'on voit la dame bon
c'est très mauvais mais au moins il
envoyait une dame quoi dame c3 beaucoup
mieux un déjà envie qui claquent adamois
montmagny j'ai reçu des millefeuilles
touch 2 et forcent l es tu vois
tu y vas du coup tu comprends les
mystères
k surréaliste sous l 621 la dent avant
l'échangeur fou de cases noires alors
ici ils pouvaient pas ici la dame elle a
attaqué et ici à la case de 4 non non
non la pohdh ks khaimah s'enfermer pas
manu de mieux dans les mois et ma nuit
il remonte un mali va te faire un petit
tour st
il va commencer à menacer des fous des
cinq ans secrète des dames b3 tour ces
trois tours c1 il va la gagner mon mât
du à laymont manu allez y les lames man
u man u man u ça genre de fabi libye
écho plus en fait manu secrète à chorfa
bibi fable ifa ville de man u bahn eu à
montmagny n'a pas vu tour st quand est
ce qu'on voit là me wade je sais pas
faire péter les sables et make me sauve
nous revoyons vlad
peut-être mais paf points et 7,6 des
trucs à capote basket je sais pas je
regarde le tchad je marche à je te cache
pas que je suis pas méga concentrer sur
la partie à des trucs qui se passent
j'ai eu des échos
maria pas n'y a pas eu cinq en larmes me
voilà ma nuit prend un pion manu à il a
pas de maths faut qu'il ait jamais messi
est mais c'est chaud en fait assez bien
joué et surtout prend il veut tour ses
huit tours ces huit dames 8 maths mais
non il fallait prendre du roi parce que
du coup vous prend b3 et la dame 8 et là
il a pris de la tour au nom et
maintenant vous prend b3 roi prend b3
d'un prend à 3 même dame à 23,3 et roy
ces deux tours ces 8es à non non il chez
qui les pleutres au nom manu renom
nantes aurait juste fait roi français
autorise juste repris du roi mon manu
s'en était tellement bien joué de la
part de manu fou prend b3 y'avait dames
élite matt manu à tia maria barbarian
neige m mais un ajout est il est dans le
dur
jean bessette la l1 peut pas isoler un
système de l'undd entre comme ça winslet
chez pas quoi
ouais c'est triste pour manu c'est
triste pour man u man u
j'espère que maniva il va faire les
points là maintenant on s'asseoit
ressassant les tours de plus
désolé pour neige mètres mais d'être 11
surveillants à regarder notre barbarian
alors ah mais c'est lui je suis à la rue
c'est un castel rouge
on le voit dans le château et j'allais
regarder c'est game vraiment c'est
triste pour pour manière notre manu
nationale qui a tombé sous liszt ou les
sous les tirs ennemis quoi pas de chance
bassem ans il envoie deux côtés il a le
sens de castel rouge mais après neuf
mois toujours du mal à gérer ses trucs
avec les blancs perso
il va prendre pas qu'il a un truc qu'il
faut pas qu'il y ait un clouage ou une
feinte est repoussé quatre ici ouais
vous c4 se fait pas mal quand même ce
que tu attaques là qui va les prendre
cavaliers prend et tu mets comme une
belle pression là-dessus fouet six
prises prise c'est peut-être même b5
maintenant mais après tout c'est un il
fit enlever le pion de la prise et qui
avait lieu à saint aignan est peut-être
un truc comme ça est sympa il a fait
pousser 4
et non amsterdam l'improbable ange a
répondu tout à l'heure mais je pourrais
probablement pas commenter le toit de
magnus commence le 14 avril avec maxime
bon c'est comme ça c'est la vie
et là il ya un flou et clouage tête du
cavalier protège la dame mais comme il
va disparaître on peut pas reprendre
ben non mais c'est pas inquiet du jeu je
répands la question c'est ce part jugé
plus développés tout alarmés je vais pas
re développer la réponse mais j'imagine
ce sera pas possible de le commenter
pour les sites autre que chess 24 je
sais pas après si c'est possible
après tout commenter non parce que ce
sera ce sera trop long mais a peut-être
les matchs de maximois pourquoi pas à
voir si c'est faisable mais j'ai peur
que ça ne soit pas malheureusement mais
bon tant pis on se parle
pas grave non on fera d'autres stream on
fera d'autres trucs artigues art cars
qu'un film qu'elle c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave il y aura le championnat 2 1
jour 2 le plus gros championnats de
sakata on va s'entraîner avec fabre qui
va avoir lieu durant 24 mois après noir
pâle moi je suis assez d'accord avec toi
sur ce que tu écris dans le chat après
ça reste ça reste des opinions
personnelles et du coup je veux pas je
veux pas trop rentrer là dedans parce
que c'est pas mon problème un chacun
fait ce qu'il veut ça après cdc des
jugements de valeur et moral et ça c'est
chacun voit midi à sa porte
c'est comme avec la religion c'est comme
avec tous ces trucs là ça après c'est
tout un chacun
tout un chacun qui voit midi à sa porte
du moment que c'est légal et que tu as
droit de le faire
voilà c'est la vie après après on a
chacun une vision différente de ce qui
est bien et mal et puis ça regarde tout
un chacun
j'aurais plus un event caritatives dans
ce type là tu vois personnellement genre
là même qu'on pète mais à mai où les
joueurs joueraient pour des associations
ça m'aurait paru plus à propos est plus
cool mais après vous savez comme tu dis
ça c'est des goûts personnels et puis à
chacun
chacun a des arguments pour ou contre
son coeur se défendent de la vision il
ya rien d'heure de mal ou bien c'est une
question de goûts et de couleurs et 2 et
division des choses donc voir il va
prendre alors comme beaucoup de pions
cassel rouge soit le matin c'est tour de
fou mais il y aura toujours quatre pions
j'aime bien dame bessette parce qu'il
veut essayer de garder ce gars on vit
qui peut être important et je viens dans
cette finale ça s'évalue commence ruch
là qui souhaitent mieux pour les blancs
comme il peut la jouer comme ça aussi
vrai
donc à faire des 5 à 5 à 6 mais tu peux
te faire bloquer les pions se passe
peut-être pas si simple à gagner sadr
est complètement gagnant quand même mais
a il y aurait trois pions ensemble je
penserai plus facile georges et 4 f 6
mai fu g5 à 5 ou des deux tu as un truc
comme ça est ce que sylvain guy c'est
pas simple même si tu as réussi ce set
ça va monter mais si tu peux largement
de tromper dans ces trucs là
donc
dong dong bang subite sa 4è oui il va y
avoir un championnat beats à quatre là
il va avoir un championnat beats à 4
mais a fait ya pas mal de trucs dont je
sais qu'il aura lui a church ascom mais
il n'y a pas deux il ya peu d'annoncés
officielles je sais pas ce qu'ils font
en fait en vrai sont un peu je pense
qu'il faut non pas l'air d'être super
efficace baptisé qui font beaucoup de ya
pas de tour des quatre là juste à tour
des garde fous ces trois à temps c'était
marrant parce qu'on va peut-être ça
gagne quand même complètement facilement
pas tour des quatre pouces et 3 donc on
est 5 vous prend 1,6 point e set et tour
des huit et tout reprend puis on prend
on apprend et à 7
donc ouais il y avait toutes les idées
comme ça tu parles trop comment ça s'est
passé dans la partie vrai mais ça va
gagner va réussir à faire tour prends
l'appareil tout reprend rêve cette tour
prend tout reprend ton roi prend et à 7
sur le même problème face à peu près ce
qui s'est passé dans la partie il faut
ramener au minimum projet de la team
francis femme de [ __ ] le nom non contre
iman il faut juste être acceptée mais
accepte tout le monde mais bien ce soir
sur le stream aux alentours de 21h sur
bitstream salta le lien de la chaîne
juste en dessous tu peux faire le petit
polo et ça va jouer vers 21h20 donc si
tu arrives à 21h17 haletant
tu as le temps donc à sa rouge on lui
aura porté bonheur
barbara ensema donc donc donc trichet
tente à face qui à la dame
ouais mais il super place et va pouvoir
rebondir et faire mal à barbarian
pourquoi c'est si tard dimanche soir dit
harvey parce qu'on joue contre le pérou
la est en fait c'est une question de
fuseaux horaires ce que ce qui est art
pour nous et eau pour le pérou c'est à
cause des des fuseaux horaires harvey
mais tu t'en reparle 21h prendre qu à
merveille son sérieux parlons entre gens
sérieux
parlons entre gens sérieux
mais non mais non mais comment tu fais
d'un proche cinq régions attenantes à
face barbarian ils arnaquent vraiment
bien à 6 volailles l'arn a quand même
beaucoup de joueurs en dessous de 2000
il faut le souligner même 2030 dans
notre tirelli chimères et lee qui
cartonne
comment tu as fait ta roll comment t'as
fait ça là j'étais foutu et a3 couillard
il dit ah ouais ça a été long beliet a
filé deux pièces de secondes par coup
tard holt a pas le droit de rater ça
t'as pas le droit
et si j'ai le droit à bordel dans c'est
dommage quand même c'est dommage
c'est très dommage donc bien plus
d'attaquant c'est toujours les mêmes les
premiers pas mais parce qu'ils sont plus
forts
c'est souvent le problème
quant à des joueurs qui sont plus forts
ils terminent souvent devant c'est ça le
problème
une question si loi il ya plusieurs
questions et voir mariam mais barbarian
avec un peu de réussite contre les
joueurs moins forts faute bien mais
c'est parce qu'il met plus de pression
aussi
et retourne beaucoup de beaucoup de
parties donc il réussi soit gagner vite
en prenant des risques mais réussit
aussi à retourner et du coup ça lui
permet d'avoir de bons résultats c'est
ce qu'il faut faire pour bien jouer et
arena en fait fonds qui a fait même
qu'ils étaient bien c'est exactement ce
qu'il faut faire prendre des risques
pour gagner vite et si ça se passe mal
être capable d'en heureux de retourner
mais aujourd'hui aurélie chez à mon gré
fort laïc et crypte talent sont bien
devant qu'elle faisait le droitier on va
aller voir ce qu'il fait il joue une
finale qui avait le droit estivale a
gagné un pion plus mais au sérieux ils
ont six points d'écart et il a le droit
cave fait marrer en fait son show auquel
j'ai le droit
on connaît d'ailleurs son vrai prénom à
cap j'ai le droit
c'était ton si à l'époque sur les pièces
avec les bears et ouais parce que
l'opposition était faible et donc
c'était faisable
le problème des arénas surface comme
maintenant c'est que toutes les deux ou
trois parties qui va jouer un mec à plus
de vingt-cinq fidh et tu peux plus faire
ça en fait tu peux plus faire du sale
mais sur ces arènes tu peux encore
qu'elle fut à presque deux heures et
déjà bravo à je suis une machine je suis
un athlète je suis en potée pas
ça va faire mal qu'elle faisait le droit
qui enchaîne les pions ouais ça c'est
une faute de carre vélo droit tu dois
fermer la baraque
tu mets ta tour ans et six tubes lindon
pions et avance là il donne un micro
contre jeu il peut plus protéger c est
bien de filet devions l'autre va
échanger les tours il va lui mettre une
tour en c3 en f3 il va essayer de
gratter les pions sacrifier la tour
contre l'autre envoyé un pion adam et
faire nul peut-être qu'elle vienne le
droit qu'a pas su fermer la porte à des
chefs qui et pleutre propose nul ça
normalement cap j'ai le droit ça va pas
lui plaire
je pense qu'il aime pas les gens pleutre
il a envoyé son pion et joue l attaque
un b 4e doit faire sa roue à ses 5
je te va bouffer essayé d'envoyer pions
1 pour essayer de couvrir et de faire
une âme gratuite on va faire ça
peut-être sa voix ça s'arrête admettons
ça ça peut vite être même très dangereux
donc faudra peut-être laissé faire des
tours c8 faire des trucs by joue pas mal
hein il suit le plan qui aviez le droit
mais a fait retour c'est un être froid
17,3 ces six tours c5 tomber cinq ans
c'est nul je pense juste et là
maintenant l'autre envoyé deux contres
jeu mais c'est très dangereux
trois sets pour ses sets 3-6 entrant
baisserait 3 prend 17 mai à tête avec 5
pour faire re rwashi 3g 5 et envoyer le
pion ça doit être nul qu'elle a par
contre à trois rois cette tourbe et 1 et
il peut même à mélopées peut-être trop
avancé il peut faire h2 toujours
difficile ces finales et il a bien joué
avec les nerfs des villes a pris les
pions il envoyer 2 contre je
très dangereux quel jeu droit qui va
peut-être la perdre dommage très dommage
si la paire a le petit oiseau qui est
très énervé aussi on va voir comment se
débrouillent son adversaire alors
il y aurait pu défendre
bon ça va enchaîner les parties un peu
ce qui se passe
non je suis content à l'idée que j'ai
mis aujourd'hui en ligne pour les
joueurs débutants c'est cool d'ailleurs
comme je dis souvent si vous débutez ray
mais là le problème c'est que
l'abonnement chess comme est pas mal n'a
pas de monde chez scop est pareils pour
les gens qui veulent progresser sans
trop débourser d'argent tour un échec 3
b 8 et g5 et quand roy se déplace chez
la tour là tu sacrifies et tu passes le
pion ont comme ça ça craignent aussi ça
faire un temps mais il a tellement d'
avance que les pions fils bon dommage
1ere illich qui continuent à dominer ce
compresseur contre 1 1200 j'avais des
risques on peut le poids ses émaux
grifols est à temps allez en fonte qui
fait mille et il a les blancs il est
perdant weyer fonds qui a faim qui
aurait pu être gagnant contre les deux
leaders et perdre mais là non et du coup
on va on va regarder un peu tiendra
gonnot ça va un moment qu'on n'est pas
lui mais j'ai vu dans le chat alors
passé à dragoon alors c'est petit quatre
cavaliers mais il pousse les pions
devant son roi avant que les noirs et
rockets si le nord avaient fait petit
rock ça aurait été moins grave là les
noirs ils vont pouvoir jouer avec grand
roque
alors après ici aurait pu enfin le truc
ça marche pas trop me quel point f6
quoique ce qui se passe quoi là sur
d'improbables 6 les mecs
qui peut me répondre dans le tchat
ouais foulée 5 et enferme la dame dont
qui force à un peu gf et x h 6 et du
coup tu bloques quand même super bien
quoi parce qu'il ya plus les ruptures h5
ya pas la rupture f5 et tu vas pouvoir
pousser de l'autre côté
donc ça ça aurait été bien joué 30 à ce
moment là en effet six essais à ces
thématiques
d'ailleurs il ya cette même thématique
dans les françaises rubinstein sur canal
et m6 ont fait preuve six dames praxis
car il y avait trois et si les noirs là
du coup du coup on fait plutôt qu'à et
17 et cavale et agissent pour reprendre
du cavale et sinon on va le protéger
leurs parts c5
il ya un flou g5 d'alger issifou des
trois dames h 5 h 3 et la dame se
retrouve assez mal quoi donc c'est un
peu cette même logique mais là ce qui
s'est passé ce qu'il allait prendre un
truc quand j'ai ici je sais pas lequel
et maintenant il se retrouve juste
massacrés sur la colonne h hatha rock
qui a pris sa revanche contre barbarian
ouais
madame 17 dans ma carte est aussi une
option
madame à 4 bizarre comme coup mais pour
revenir vers f4 en fait je pensais c4
est il fou des cinq défend quand même
bien encore trop tard il est beaucoup
moins bien mais c'est pas complètement
perdue puisque il défend encore sur
blanc
il couvre encore sur blanc c'est jusqu'à
quelle heure le tournoi c'est jusqu'à 45
rock star du net
ah non c'est bien ce qui fait la grande
trottoir il ya mille fois en défense et
ils contre-attaquent de l'autre côté on
a appris que les cinq qui fait un peu la
gueule caïds et 4 ce qui va perdre le
pur malheureusement mais je trouve que
c'est plutôt bien stratégiquement ce
qu'il a voulu faire après c'était plutôt
bien mais ça va pas suffire
j'aime bien encore un coin intermédiares
il a des bons réflexes
mais bon allez dam des trois ça évite de
se prendre ce truc là je serais plutôt
lent détroit pour essayer de toucher sa
l'entourage fuite et va et mesdames à 6
face au miroir des 8 mai essayer de
faire peur bon
ces faits pions b4 c'était pas une
erreur va ester venu bien avant l'airé
pions bekkat il a tenté quelque chose je
peux pas critiquer ce coup là le
problème maintenant c'est que en plus il
va sur la colonne h et à tour ici fou
ici et qualité revient et ça va bien se
passer un pur projet doit encore mieux
va faire d'alger 4 et ça être finie
tient une fin de partie cryptage
j'étale qui a pas internet à mettre à
son endroit plus de tout peut pas faire
tomber cristal qui s'est mis dans le dur
tiens ça ça un nouveau jamais vu joueurs
alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer ici un
cavalier enfermé non qu'est ce qu'il a
fait c'est mike comment on en est arrivé
là
stinat les qui n'allait keynes pas
forcément une ouverture se passe suffit
d'apprendre la liquide et sarsat à
transposer une pierre qui donc
commencent à avancer a été pris le
machin alors faire qui a aidé 5-1
malheureusement pas par action et jouer
avec ce que faire d'autre
c'est moche mais ça joue quoi pas plus
le choix
dommage pour cette night était bien
classé mais j jv 69 qui peut refaire une
belle perf on va voir
à la 76e ricky ray mais on lit pas le
tchatcheur bref s'il ya trop de chatte
sinon ce qu'il écrivait je vais faire
1924 d'icub eric je vais me coucher pas
quels lots au cube eric quel est ton
lots c'est une belle perf ça c'est même
une très belle perf une 450 mille six
cents
ok quels sont vos hauts faits d'armé
exactement pierrot là tu peut parfois
avoir l'idée de jouer des cavaliers à
trois qui on prend qui on prend et mater
sur noir ça peut être une idée
si le chat futur que je suis pas trop s
avec peut pas avoir tout ouvert après
c'est un problème on peut pas voir
s'ouvrir alors autour des 3 il menaça
l'a peut-être tout reprend à trois pions
prend aidé à me prendre trois buts a
quand même récupéré une calloc'h epyon
des toujours en vie ça peut sarah kay
sont vos sources pour pinatar et ça
c'est devenu tellement à la mode demande
de vendée les sources
ça a été du fait qu'il y beaucoup de
fake news j'imagine quand tu dis les
plans une d'écouter les fonds c'est
possible mais du coup ils font n'importe
quoi parfois
enfin des trucs comme tout reprend ses
deux a regardé on va prendre dames 3 2
avec l'écumé asbe un tour b un seul coup
et tour échec mais là il y accueille ces
trois parce que surtout repenser troyat
dang tran mais c'est genre d'idées qui
peuvent exister
donc on peut quand même la gagne 1
comment on fait pour rejoindre tournoi
patrick je te mets lien citer adam le
deutsches comme france tu peux y arriver
après le tournoi il ferme il ferme
bientôt patrick du 9 5 se termine dans
15 minutes
oh lalala lalala est ce qu'il va devoir
aux ja m'attends à un belle perf de
givet à 69 belle perf
bon alors là maintenant le toit à vis de
la grèce va jouer entre maugrey fola
irait illich peut-être un peu suivre les
2 et restent pas longtemps qu avec
monique simard et eu la charge de
travail pour un jour environ 1000 sept
ans passés à 2002 voire maîtres phil hay
si tu travailles ça dépend déjà de ton
âge par l'état 117 ça dépend de avec qui
tu t'entraînes tu dépends de beaucoup de
choses et on va dire si tu travailles
une quinzaine d'heures par semaine
pendant quatre cinq ans ça devrait
pouvoir le faire mais après ça dépend de
ton âge ces pans de beaucoup de choses
ces pans de comment tu travailles aussi
mike à sa ruche c'est dangereux en fait
l'incident parce que vous avez un
décalage donc c'est très dangereux
alors faut aussi qu'ils tentent l'aréna
est arrivé un peu tard malheureusement
tuera pas beaucoup de parties t'as 40
ans non mais si tu fais ça tu peux y
arriver
après tu seras heureux pauleta par
l'état qui devait être supporters du psg
il ya il ya vingt ans quand quand
c'était encore le psg une peut-être
bordeaux qui sait
à l'époque c'était encore respectable
le respectable et géré par là qu'il ya
plein de nouveaux supporters qui sont
arrivés par la suite
ils sont pas les supporters historiques
on va dire ces différents moyens vis le
côté supporters historiques que l'équipe
marche ou pas des gars l'action de
toujours des râleurs équipe je trouve ça
je trouve ça plus cool que les gens qui
qui navigue un peu au gré des des
transferts et genre semble que malgré
cela il va battre josy wael cinq ans
vous me dites les traits sans son indice
les 700 sont imbattables
j'ai supporters de toulouse
ouais bah ya beaucoup de noms mais les
gens qui surprend le pen est depuis
longtemps c'est très bien bravo juste à
taper argent qui deviennent supporters
du psg
jodi white soyons mailly 700 sont
réforme à charbon ils sont forts ils
sont plus forts que les 700 habituel ça
c'est pas faux mais peut-être du cndd
bague mais ils sont quand même battable
par le chassé croisé continue mais assez
relish enchaîne les victoires il va
gagner on va voir
allez grand roque 5 c'est bien joué je
suis plus âgé de 74 et bien sûr non mais
tu as ça j'apprécie j'apprécie patrick
du 95
chacun à chacun son club bien sûr bien
sûr bien sûr mais j'aime bien les gens
qui changent pas de club comme toi qui
sont pour un club et puis voilà que ça
se passe bien que ça se passe mal ça ils
font ce qu'ils peuvent quoi
après du couteau en tant que porte
supporters du psg qu'est ce que tu
penses de tant que supporter du psg ou
partez pas représenter un supporter du
psg mais géré par là tu penses quoi tous
ces gens qui viennent du coup maintenant
qui est une grosse équipe
est-ce que tu ne dis pas c'est cd sony
supporters quoi tu penses que tu en
penses
du coup c'est une vraie question
c'était à l'époque de le guen et tout ça
aussi daniel bravo georges weah il ya eu
des belles équipes et des beaux joueurs
c'est juste qu'en matière de culture
foot on est parent ont selon support
juge les vainqueurs ouais c'est dommage
je trouve je trouve ça lui aurélien
bonjour à toi qui écris yo yo du coup
le fc gueugnon le fc gueugnon ils sont
devenus quadeurs il n'existe plus il
était en ligue 1 un an la fc gueugnon
booster ligue 2
c'était en ligue 2 mst ou venant ces
genres et une toute petite ville mais
d'aller jouer voilà une coupe d'europe
c'est ça il avait gagné une coupe way
en finale ouais je me rappelle de ça
c'était fou mais du coup il était il
était en cfa même il y avait eu qu'à
l'est aussi si vous vous rappelez
stehlik de ré mais ils ont disparu
détendez 2
je suis génial petit super mais je suis
aurait étonné de voir des victoires et
des différences de niveaux aussi
important d'un mais ça arrive du neo
c'est juste que normalement les joueurs
avec intel une telle différence et l'eau
joue pas ensemble mais en vrai 300 400
points en blitz à les surprises ça ça
arrive assez fréquemment pas fréquemment
battus à une partie sur 10 mai mais
c'est quand même fréquent du coup
donc pas sûr qu'ils la gagnent c'est la
riche
janet que vous parlez du psg je suis
grand supporter de juin juge était à
paris pour le match psg vu de platini et
bonera et mais ça ça ça remonte chez
miramax 1 c'est beau ça les supporters
de la louve
c'est un bon club bravo
je tiendrai là alors il faut ce sera
juste mais ce soir du coup à le match
contre le match contre le pérou vers 21h
si vous pouvez être dans le coin 21h20
sera sur la chaîne vitrine vous allez
viens juste en dessous si vous n'êtes si
vous aussi vous ne ferez pas encore
j'imagine que beaucoup de gens follow en
tout cas je l'espère
donc non je vais pas passer à 12h tu
m'as tu as peut-être plus d'effet que
news c'est pas dans mon objectif j'ai
pas le temps ça me prendrait beaucoup de
temps et de travail j'ai juste pas le
temps alloué à pour faire ça ah ouais le
match auxerre dortmund le pied aux
français c'est 21h20 je crois guy roux
qui pète un câble et qui va chercher les
ballons c'est ça le bail avec les
supporters qui ont gardé les ballons et
qui va chercher les ballons et après il
avait pété un câble c'est chez nokia
nisand qui a largement le niveau
peut-être il me troll un petit peu fous
de ma gueule possible ou pas peut-être
qu'il le pense vraiment pense à rien je
sais pas qui c'est en vrai je me les
pseudos mais je sais pas qui c'est mais
jugez pas le temps
avec j'arrête de stream pas que je
divorce sa demande
ça me demanderait de faire des efforts
que je ne suis pas prêt à faire donc je
serai pas émis après si ça passe en
rapide pourquoi pas peut-être
j'essaierai ou en blitz
c'est daniel roth et j'ai joué peut-être
contre lui quand j'étais gamin je pense
une accession c'est peut-être son frère
c'est peut-être contre son frère j'ai
perdu je pense m scandinave détroit
j'aime bien phu en g4 et je suis il est
peut-être fenioux j'avais perdu chez
plus un divorce jusque là c'est aller
mes amis jusque là je pense pas que ma
famille soit super course il dit
j'arrête de bosser je vais faire
foulletons à des chèques j'aurai mon à
la maison et à cuire tout reprend 17
double échec
est ce que tu crois que tu avais vol est
mis en lice
je l'avais ça c'est sûr
est ce que je lui ai encore pas sur un
je sais pas mais à l'époque je jouais
bien en bis
quand j'ai des tournois réels je fais
souvent des perf au dessus de 24,50 25
j'étais un très bon mitzach mais
aujourd'hui je sais pas tu vois blitz
sur internet sur ça c'est sûr en fait il
suffit juste de voir les partis sur une
chaise comme dans l'est sur les trucs
contre 2007 sur czech comme généralement
c'est pas le niveau mais a émigré en mai
je pense pas grand match je pense pas
nami peut-être je sais pas c'est
difficile de juger mais à wes a fait à
peu près ça on va dire de me entre 2007
et 2008 sur czech comme envers 2007 ces
niveaux a émis et 2008 ces tortues fait
l'énorme quelque chose comme ça aurait
peut-être je sais pas c'est difficile de
s'auto juger mais peut-être
surtout dans les arénas je m'en sors pas
mal et où donc est peut-être mais à
mais bon je vais pas y aller mater des
vidéos pour passer de 2500 en 2007 sur
chaise comme non non non je ma tronche
si je peux travailler les échecs je
regarde pas de vidéo fait comme beaucoup
si vous êtes bon dans un domaine après
les vidéos c'est juste une manière plus
compliqué d'apprendre c'est plus ludique
mais c'est plus difficile c'est plus
facile sur un livre et maugrey faux
laïques et pas forcément très bien mais
le truc c'est que oui puisqu'il n'ya pas
d'amis huit tours f8 kg 6 ouais mais le
tas plus de temps qu'il prend est fuite
à pied et prend la fuite fallait
peut-être tentés et tours 7
c'est à l'autre allait prendre le père
pète et tout recettes directes vous
prendrez g8 matin il y avait tout
recette qui gagne
et maintenant il va la perdre
il a raté de dann g8 match mais il était
dur à voir mais maintenant il va la
perdre
jusqu'à 200 pour des exercices
pédagogiques simple faut qu' il ya
ceschi dana morpho ci qui est en train
de tout traduire en français et je pense
que ça va être bien pour les enfants
pour les pour les tout petits
alors en fait ça a joué sur réélisant
relish qui peut perdre le ton à la co
parce que mon gré faux l'oeil est devant
et si relish marque pas de points
il finira deuxième membres élisent qui
peut perdre le ton à la cour c'est moche
pour relish le problème de quoi il va
être déconnecté pour avoir c'est moche
pour relish erelis gagnera pas le
tournoi les amis il avait 17 sur 17
comme au gré aux mots grecs jouent
contre le charpentier et il perd le
tournoi à qu assez moche pour relish
c'est très moche pour riches
vous voulez quoi c'est vrai
donc
c'est dommage
c'est dommage elle charpentier way un
truc s'il assume 30
ça va ça va ça va faire nul normalement
relish qui repartit mis la puce trixie
fait nul il marquera qu'un point mais
jouer une finale c'est dommage pour lui
son sac le charpentier fait pas la
partie de l'année mais le truc c'est
qu'il faut pas qu'ils abandonnent le
charpentier la folle affaire à la
pleutre tu laisses d'écouler le temps et
tu fais nul donc donc donc vous prêtez
affaire qui va faire nul du coup par
obligation et relish aussi ouais mais
comme j'étais riche comme il a pu le
streak qui va marquer qu'un point et
maugrée 2
donc ça va faire une victoire pour
maugrée mais les deux joueurs qui ont
été impressionnants qui ont tout gagné
et à est en fait sinon il aurait fait
égalité et j'aurais fait mieux nul il
aurait fait l'égalité je crois que
c'était mauvais qu'un meilleur des
partages aussi donc
donc ça ce serait fini avec le même
résultat probablement si mes calculs
sont bons ce chèque et comment de faire
le premier tiers
mais sachez qui a été en tête ou a par
contre été a donné là nul donc maugrée
premier battu marque qu'un point mais
avec le streak en cas de nul a donc créé
liste ya pas de boy leur effet nul là il
aurait quand même fini 2e bon et du coup
barbarian troisième donc c'est toujours
les mêmes joueurs qui se battent en haut
de tableau
sur ce les mecs ce soir donc 21h et
quelques il y aura le match contre le
pérou donc j'espère que vous serez
nombreux en notre compagnie pour les
battre et puis mois ci à l'aréna 17h ou
18h je reviendrai en fera l'entraînement
beats à quatre avec fabre on commencera
et bah écoute et à bientôt enfin tout à
l'heure bah c'est un beau début d'après
midi je vais je mets une pub si vous
voulez soutenir un peu de chasse comme
pour tous les scream qu'on fait à la
pause déjeuner n'hésitez pas à moi je
vous mets la petite pub ci voulait pas
la regarder tant pis je voulais aller
s'est ouverte tant mieux et puis à
atouts ciao ciao et sera sur la chaîne
big three de les autres stream auquel le
lien juste en dessous on va les dégommer
les péruviens tout à fait parole